you know when i started this channel i
had absolutely no idea where it was
going to go
or where we would end up two years later
we just surpassed
10 000 subscribers
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today is a very special and very
momentous day for me
because we've just surpassed 10 000
subscribers on this channel
like i said i didn't really know where
this channel was gonna go from the start
i wasn't really sure
what we're gonna do with it it started
off as a fitness vlog with a little bit
of technology mixed in between
and it slowly progressed to some sort of
tech reviews
eventually i figured out that i was kind
of out of my element with technology
reviews because
i couldn't actually financially afford
to be buying the latest and greatest
tech every single week
it ended up just putting me in a massive
hole and getting no return
so i thought i might as well do what i'm
truly passionate about and talk to you
guys about architecture
and mix it in with technology as much as
possible over the past few months i have
been doing a lot more architecture
related videos and archicad related
tutorials
which you guys have been absolutely
loving and it has made this channel grow
immensely especially over the last two
three months where it's just spiked like
crazy so before we really dive into this
q a
where i got all these questions from
instagram from you guys
i just wanted to say thank you for
supporting me thank you for supporting
this channel
and together over the next few years
we're going to continue to grow this
to the best community we absolutely can
i know personally as an architect it's
very hard to communicate
about architecture with other architects
everything seems to be a secret for some
reason
but i don't really want it to be that
way i want to be able to change the
world
somehow some way shape or form and in
some weird way this is my way of doing
that
so there is a discord link down below if
you guys want to join the discord group
and start building this community even
more so so
whenever you need some help if it's
architecture related if it's student
related
hopefully either myself or somebody in
the community can help you but without
further ado i think we should start
getting into these questions
i took notes over the week of all the
questions that came through and i
thought there was a couple good ones in
there
so i picked out i think my top 15 or 16
there is
here and i just really wanted to just
share my experience with you guys and
answer the questions that you have
usually i reply to every single comment
you make on youtube but there's some
questions that just genuinely need
some sort of realistic personal touch so
i'll literally
go at no particular order whatsoever and
i'm gonna go through the list
as i wrote them down and as they came in
if this question does come from you
thanks so much for asking the question i
hope i've answered it
exactly how you were looking for the
first question is do you prefer
revit or archicad i think that's kind of
become more apparent over the past
couple years
it's more so moving towards archicad
than revit
revit was my bread and butter it's where
i learnt the basics of architecture
is where i learned to become an
architect but archicad is something that
i've adopted over the past couple of
years
and i've actually grown to like it so
much more i think now archicad is my
preferred software even though i still
do believe revit has
so many more features that arcade
doesn't but i do believe for my
situation
and the purposes of what i do in
day-to-day life archicad is a much
better software the next question is do
you use photoshop
indesign or illustrator much if yes how
did you learn it
um i don't use indesign and illustrator
that much i do use photoshop
quite often i think indesign we kind of
get the grads to do that more so to
compile documents and presentation bits
and pieces but it was definitely
something i have used and i do know
very well i know the whole w suite
pretty well actually
it's something i learned in university
so i started my university life
as a psychology undergrad i decided that
wasn't for me so i transferred into a
graphic design course because
architecture only actually started at
the start of the year
and i wanted to transition midway
through so i decided to not waste time
not go on the workforce
and pick up a skill that might actually
help me in architecture career
so yeah i did graphic design for six
months where i learned photoshop
illustrator indesign
premiere pro basically the whole adobe
suite and that skill has
literally helped me from day one in my
architecture career
and at university all the way now as a
fully qualified architect the next
question is did you mostly learn cad
through uni or did you have to
self-teach yourself um
it's a bit of a mixed bag because at
university
at least at my university everything was
self-taught we had a small revit class
that ran for one semester and they
taught you the absolute basics
but i wanted to know all the programs to
be able to kind of best position myself
when i came out of university for
the workforce so i learned archicad i
learnt rhino i learned
autocad i learned archicad i learnt them
all during university myself
and then obviously as i transitioned
into the workforce i learned more and
more of these skills
my first job was at a revit firm so i
learned revit quite well
and then i progressed into archicad
firms from there and i've used archicad
since
so it's a bit of a mix originally
self-taught and then obviously taught by
the people
that know it better than me who've been
working in the field longer than me and
cons of becoming a drafts person versus
a qualified architect
i guess this question is hard to answer
because the situation around the world
is completely different for drafts
people and architects
in my personal experience i guess drafts
people
don't really design as much as
architects the whole purpose of an
architect
is to be able to get that experience and
qualifications
into the design elements so we start
from
sketch design with a very first sketch
and work it all the way through the
project
whereas the drafts person kind of gets
handed over the job at a certain point
in my experience at least it could be
different around the world
i think the pros and cons are kind of
simple more creativity and more freedom
as an architect
kind of more of a very repetitive job as
a drafts person
the pay is obviously greater as an
architect versus a drafts person because
obviously you have
a higher set of qualifications and a
degree in architecture as well as
multiple years experience
you have all sorts of criteria that you
have to fill
whereas for a drafts person you don't
have to have the same qualifications
it's a much quicker course a much
shorter course but that doesn't take
anything away from drafts people
they do know how to do construction
details sometimes a lot better than
architects
because that is their job to know how to
detail and how to construct
drawings a lot better than what
architects necessarily might know or do
know did you make this with twin motion
they're referring to this render here
that i posted on my instagram
a couple days ago yes that was made with
twin motion with a little bit of
photoshop
afterwards so i think from memory all i
did was
export it in twin motion and then i did
a sky replacement in photoshop because
the skies and twin motion are a bit
average
um there wasn't really too much more in
photoshop literally a 30 second sky
replacement
so yep most of the renders you see on my
page are done with twin motion
if they're not i'll specify it or i'll
tag somebody that i collaborated with to
create that render this is a big
question because it's something that
applies to a lot of people including
myself at the start
how do i find a job with zero experience
if every application ad
asks for two years minimum it's a very
tough question because i go out and hire
new grads now and i look for
a magnitude of different things most of
the time i do ask for some experience
but it's not always necessary
i think you have to position yourself in
the best way possible and position your
portfolio
to that firm so if they are asking for
two years experience you can still apply
that doesn't mean you won't get it
but if you do need that two years
experience and you're seeing yourself
knock-backed over and over and over
again
then just go out and get a temporary
free unpaid summer internship or a
winter internship
jay's do it for a whole year if you have
to i know i did about three months of
unpaid interns before i got my first
paid job
because to be honest even as a masters
of architecture graduate
with a fully five-year qualified degree
at university you still don't know
anything
in the field it took me a very long time
to figure that out
but eventually i did and i realized that
i was way too cocky coming out of
university
as what i should be so i think that's
why most people actually put in that two
years minimum
experience because you realize how much
you don't know
and how much more you have to learn and
that puts you in a much stronger
position
next question is how beneficial is
archicad for quantity surveyors can they
become an architect too
multiple part questions i guess anybody
can become an architect as long as you
have the correct qualifications and
you've gone down the right pathway
um if you're a fully qualified quantity
surveyor
there is some benefits to using archicad
i guess there is
ways you can implement quantity
surveying into archicad so you could get
an architect to send you their model
and you could implement that into your
software with all your data i know
exactly how much that building is going
to cost
there is a lot better quantity surveying
software's out there
you wouldn't necessarily be going to
archicad for a qs position
um so i think there is benefit in
learning it you know how to manipulate
models you can check out bits and pieces
but you probably only need to learn the
basics you wouldn't have to learn
anything further
next question is how would you rank your
top five passions gym
architecture technology etc first and
foremost i think my biggest passion is
being
somewhat of an entrepreneur i've been an
entrepreneur ever since i was about 18
i've pushed my own businesses i've tried
to build my own brands i've
dedicated my time to helping others grow
their businesses
and just being a better business person
in general so i find myself always
positioned in an area
where i am the entrepreneur in the
situation
that would be my biggest passion and
then i guess architecture would follow
suit following that it would actually be
fitness
it would be the gym only because i think
all the workload and stress
of being an entrepreneur and being an
architect and having a full-time job
multiple businesses on the side multiple
companies running at the same time
international ventures and all sorts of
bits and pieces
you end up just losing so much sleep and
just getting absolutely wrecked
sometimes so
from a mental point of view and just
self-care and self-discipline i think
fitness comes in at number three for me
because it's just genuinely a stress
relief and it
helps me clear my mind in the mornings
and then start my day as best as
possible after that technology would
come in
at a very close fourth i absolutely
love technology i love buying new tech
it always excites me
opening up technology and ripping it
open playing with the first time
setting it up it's just i don't know
something about it that i've loved ever
since i was a kid
ever since i used to play video games as
a kid i always just loved technology
as much as i could question is do you
think
you need to be super creative to become
a drafts person or an architect uh yes
or no you don't really need to be super
creative to become a drafts person
you're usually told what to do or how to
do something you need to be
quite creative in a sense to be able to
problem solve but
i don't think you need to be creative in
a sense to understand materiality
shapes and all the things that an
architect does
in the early stages you don't exactly
need to be creative as an architect
either you can be very successful
by doing just plain boxes minimalistic
architecture in my opinion is one of the
hardest things to successfully achieve
and
most people just go well it's just a box
but to somebody who's
truly mastered minimalistic architecture
it is the most creative
but yet the least creative thing you can
do but again
not taking anything away from drafts
people because they do an exceptional
job at what their job
is every job role is very different and
i think we have to understand what one
job role is versus what another job role
is
would be keen to know more about
workflow utilizing the renovations tool
how best to model your existing
then add proposed designs i did a video
a couple weeks back
on renovation layers and how i use them
it was more so about setting up
renovation layers than anything else
the way i do it personally is i model
the whole building that i'm working with
if it's an alteration edition
and then i look at it from a structural
point of view as to not blow out costs
so if i was going to blow out costs i'd
just knock the whole thing down start
again because it's much more feasible
but the reason you keep an alteration
addition is to keep the solid
and structural elements going so you can
just build up and build around and not
have to worry about spending
that 150 200 300 000 whatever it might
be that's already there
so for me it's about learning the floor
plans learning what that existing area
is and then
building and designing something that
works to that
rather than completely against that so
it's to complement the existing design
as much as possible and to utilize
the existing structure as much as
possible this question was actually
asked a couple times in a couple
different ways
so the simplest way i wrote this one
down is what's the best way to prepare
for architecture school
architecture school is diverse and it's
different
and it's strange it doesn't matter where
you study it across the world
my first day was life drawings of naked
people not what i'd expect that
university is an architecture student
and then it got a bit more creative and
a bit more different so preparing for
architecture school
is more so about preparing yourself for
the curriculum and understanding what
you're getting into
read the curriculum learn what programs
they use learn what they're expecting
check out what some of the current
students are doing see if you have any
idea of how they
even got to that point learn things like
photoshop indesign illustrator
archicad autocad revit learn as much as
you can to prepare
or at least just watch youtube videos on
it so you know the fundamental basics
you're going to be absolutely
overwhelmed at architecture school it
doesn't matter how much you prepare
because there is so much to learn so
just take it with a pinch salt go in
with an open mind
and remember to keep pushing through
because the first couple years of
architecture school
are by far the hardest they're the most
challenging
and they really get you to start
thinking differently especially coming
straight out of high school
so don't be afraid in university just go
in with an open mind and
keep going is my only advice really how
much technical drawing
does one do in architecture school this
does vary depending on schools so
i know we didn't do very much we did
very
minimal technical drawing we had one
unit on it every single semester but it
wasn't
amazing like i'm not gonna lie it wasn't
the best technical drawing i didn't
learn a lot
i definitely learned a lot more going
out to the practice in the real world
so you will do some but you kind of
babied your way through it
well in my experience maybe in different
universities and different colleges
you'll have a much different experience
but usually it does
form one of your four core subjects at
university per
semester how much math does one do in
architecture school and do i need to be
super good at it
i genuinely don't do very much math in
architecture it's very simple maths
to be fair though and to be honest i've
been very good at math during
high school during university and
everything it was one of my best
subjects so
math kind of came naturally to me um
it's not something you specifically need
every day
but you do need to i don't know add
subtract
to multiply the basics you don't need to
go and learn
physics and you don't really need to go
and learn what engineers learn
but having said that i know america for
example as an architect you do a lot
more
in an architect's role than you do in an
australian architect's role and that's
why
our degrees aren't recognized in
different countries because we all have
different rules different regulations
and different understandings of the job
role so in australia at least you don't
need to know
an excessive amount of maths but it's
always good to know the fundamental
basics which
i'm sure you probably have to know to
get into university
at some way shape or form can you speak
serbian
do you have balkan roots yes yes i can
speak serbian i can speak creation
technically it's the same language just
different dialogue
um i was born in bosnia i was raised
there for a few years and we moved to
australia when i was three
so i do have balkan roots i haven't been
back for a very very long time nor do i
think i'll be going back at any point in
time
soon because of the whole covert
situation so um
yes i can speak serbian if you do
comment in serbian or in croatian down
below i tend to reply in serbian
equation if you've noticed
but yeah i guess english is now my first
language because
i learned creation first i spoke until i
was three and then i started speaking
english since and i only spoke creation
at home to my parents and to my grandma
because my grandma of course didn't know
any english she was in her late 60s when
we moved
and she never really learned english so
it was the only way i could communicate
with her
last question mac or microsoft pros and
cons
for each that is a huge huge huge
question that i could talk about for
hours and hours and hours
simplest way to put it mac is more
user-friendly
windows is more tech friendly so
if you're a bit of a geek like me and
understand technology a little bit more
windows is super helpful because you can
manipulate it and play with it
and do whatever you want most custom pcs
are a lot more powerful
than any mac os computer that's out on
the market at the moment
the mac m1 chip at the moment is killing
it it is
pushing some numbers way better than
anything that is on the market
for an intel chip so i don't know maybe
the next couple years depending on what
how apple actually
pushes their chips and what they plan on
doing
apple m1 chips might be a lot more
powerful and better graphics processing
than a windows pc
but yet to see if you just want to get
on with your day and have a really good
ui
mac for sure if you want to kind of
spend a bit more time nerding out about
it
windows always the best option anyway
that's all the questions from you guys
today thank you so much for taking the
time to putting those together
it truly does mean something to me
because all these videos that i put out
for you guys it means that somebody is
actually watching
and it makes it a little bit more real
it's not that number just ticking over
and over and over every day
and going up and up and up it's actual
genuine real life people around the
world coming together creating a
community
asking questions growing together so i
know we are still
a very small community on the youtube
scale 10 000 is a huge number for me
and a very big success in my goals for
this year i was aiming for about 10
000 at the end of the year we're only in
may we're
so far ahead of schedule which is
absolutely incredible thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed the video
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below hit that like button
too
apparently it helps with the youtube
algorithm i know it's been helping in
the past few weeks so thank you for
hitting it
and as always i will see you next monday